[Music]
will you please state your name for the
record
please welcome pamela anderson
did you know anything at all about mr
lee before you met him
i knew he was the drummer for mommy crew
did you find him attractive i like to
smile
i still do
[Music]
we're so good together
it's everlasting love
we have recently come into possession of
a piece of
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is material
private it's like we're seeing something
we're not supposed to be saying
nobody's ever getting rich off a
celebrity sex tape what if we sold it
someplace nobody could find us a website
about what song it's this thing on the
computer people will order the tape
directly from us
wow you are so hot
what the hell is this
how many copies of this are out there
could be doesn't
pirated copies are sprouting up all over
the web you don't seem to understand
what a big deal this is i'm on that tape
just the same as you but this is worse
for me how is this worse for you
is that how you feel like you have to
please people that's all i do
anything
[Music]
you